these are mud puddle frogs in a
Panamanian rainforest locked in a mating
embrace designed to produce more mud
puddle frogs as the male fertilizes the
eggs something pretty amazing also
occurs the male frogs legs make like a
Mixmaster stuck in the puree mode he
whips up the fluid released with the
females eggs into a nest of foam that
looks big enough to top off 500 double
cappuccinos
sometimes other couples join the party
creating a frothy nursery and daycare
center for their eggs the foam keeps the
eggs moist and full of oxygen and also
hides them from predators and now let's
face it isn't it always better if my
foam home is higher than your foam home
it just never ends does it